ashley's in west palm beach california
hi ashley how are you west palm beach
david florida florida i would think yeah
i saw that on the screen and read it
like i was anchorman or something okay
so i knew better as i was reading it how
can we help
uh well um i am currently in baby step
two
and i have a about ten thousand dollars
left on a student loan
however it's currently in part of the
class action lawsuit so
i'm not required to make any payments on
it um so i've been using
what i would have paid on that towards
the rest of my snowball
um it's not currently accruing any
interest anything like that
um i'm just not sure if i should pay it
off what is the uh
what's the nature of the class action
lawsuit
uh it was for false advertising for job
placement rates
um and things like that so it was for
like a technical school
technical school still open no they're
closed
they went broke shut down well your
student your student loan is
your student loan is supposed to be
forgiven under federal guidelines
in that situation anyway well i was
i had already graduated from the school
doesn't matter that happened so i wasn't
currently
really yeah doesn't matter if the school
closed due to
if the school went bankrupt it's an
indication that they were running a scam
and the fed one of the federal it's one
of the few types of student loan
forgiveness that actually does occur
you can you actually get a high rate of
these that are forgiven
so you need to get in touch with the
feds and work that through you said it's
a ten thousand dollar balance and it's
your only debt left
uh it's why i have two left i have about
eight thousand left on a credit card but
i've been using the student loan payment
to pay down the credit card faster since
i've not been required to pay payments
on the student loan yeah
okay well yeah what i'd do is knock the
credit card out and then i would save up
ten thousand dollars extra
above your normal emergency fund of
three to six months
so that if this all falls apart you can
write a check and be out of debt
that's what i thought you'd say but i
just i needed to hear it from you yeah
but in the meantime you need to
investigate the federal
uh you know get on the websites with the
feds because i think you're going to get
this whole thing forgiven anyway
regardless of the class action
okay now do you think they would forgive
and reimburse forever anything that i've
paid
that's my concern no it's just a
freaking no the fed the feds don't
guarantee
that schools don't go broke but they do
forgive
federally insured student loans on
schools that close
okay regardless of your career if you're
a current student or not
yes yeah okay double check it jump in on
the student loan websites
and uh uh james that site that you sent
me the other day that had the different
types on it do you remember what it was
off the top of your head
that'll touch my head but i can find it
incentive okay yeah well
she'll be going by then but anyway yeah
it's so but there there's a site we were
just looking at the other day
and uh you know there's two or three
types of student loan forgiveness that
actually do occur that's all
yeah that's what i was about to say
because usually it's one of those
impossible things that
it's a dream that people have that's
going to happen and it usually doesn't
it's called the but the pslf is the one
that sucks that everybody thinks is
going to happen and nobody gets
it doesn't doesn't really occur yeah and
so the public stu
public service student loan forgiveness
after 10 years and that's what
so many people are betting the farm on
and they're getting screwed
yeah and the current numbers we just
pulled this up the other day
off the site that we were talking about
here
the 227 thousand people have applied for
that
and only three thousand have gotten it
so it's less
it's about one percent of the of the ten
year yeah that ten year type now the
type that she has
were a closed school discharge it would
be 100 or a discharge due to death or a
discharge due to disability
or there's an another one for teachers
and sometimes nurses that do the inner
city the or the rural
underserved areas they're called that's
a five-year plan and those students
there's a high rate of the forgiveness
on those but the public service student
loan forgiveness one is the ones that
joke yep so it's education data.org
say it again educationdata.org so if
you're still there
it's education data.org
educationdata.org or data.org
and um yeah that's where you can start
to find out this
this deal but the the if you went to and
a lot of them were
very few very few times just like a
four-year university close
right but there were a lot of these uh
vo-tech things a truck-driving school
a computer programming school or
whatever
and you go in there and they run the
student that basically they're running a
scam to
you know get people signed student loans
they cash in all the money they take off
and the school closes
how does that happen uh often enough
that they decided to put it in the
deadline
too often yeah it's not say everybody in
that space is slimy but there was enough
slime in that space
that the discharge due to school closing
is a thing yeah
that's a thing and you don't have to do
it through a class action
so jump in there and learn about it and
you can get the details
and get moving on